[Music]
foreign
this was how it started the Russian
onslaught
shocking but also shambolic
these Russian troops invaded from next
door Belarus only to be beaten back
[Music]
12 months on this piece of Ukraine's
broken Border in the north is bristling
with bolstered defenses
new lines of trenches where they watch
and wait
um
no one drops their guard in case Moscow
tries again
the Border guard
regarded his Focus but for now at least
it's concentrated on the east and south
it's a challenge Ukraine's president
addressed for the 365th night in a row
it is here on our land that we are
protecting the very values that underpin
the life of not only our people but also
the vast majority of European nations
got it to our Warriors glory to each and
every one who is now in combat thank you
to everyone who helps us glory to
Ukraine
this country has been gutted by War
the scars run deepest here in the east
Ern Village
on the first day of the second year of
this war Ukraine remains defiant but the
fighting is only set to intensify
neither side right now has the strength
to achieve a decisive Victory but no
one's in the mood for compromise it
means there'll be many more painful days
months possibly even years
in the capital each flag is planted in
memory of the Fallen
a growing Garden of grief
and sacrifice
debraham Sky News Keith